[Music]
bachelor nation's newest engaged couple
tell DT even they were surprised when
producers announced their big news we
got a little warning that there was
gonna be a tease the next day and then
we woke up two boards and Beyond it one
day and I was like wait we gotta call
grandma right now Ashley I can Eddie and
Jared Haven net on bachelor in paradise
three years ago and will appear on the
show again when it returns in August the
couple plans to tie the knot next summer
I'm your wedding be bigger small big
will actually wear a sleek dress or ball
gown ball gown
will you marry in paradise or not
probably not these two will they say
they have lived a real life together
long enough to know they have what it
takes to make it last The Bachelor
trouble you know you kid it's so
romanticize it's like a big fairy tale
that when you leave it it's like
bursting the bubble and you're like whoa
real life do I like you in real life
yeah we're the helicopters and the Roses
what's going on
[Music]